Speaker 1: And speaking of ballots,
we got a new very interesting poll from
the state of New Hampshire this week.
According to this new New Hampshire poll for
the Republican 2024 presidential primary in the
ever important state of New Hampshire,
just because it's an early state,
Ron DeSantis, the authoritarian governor here in
my state of Florida, is now ahead of Donald Trump.
But he's not just the head. That's not
all that's happened here. He hasn't just
taken a lead. He has closed a 25
point gap between Trump and DeSantis.
DeSantis closed a 25 point gap between the two
that existed all the way back in October of 2021.
Back then, Trump had 4840 3%
of the vote to Santos had 18%.
Today, DeSantis has 39% and Trump has 37.
Still within the margin of error. So, you know,
Trump doesn't need to sound the alarm bells
just yet. But this is an early primary state.
If DeSantis enters this race. And outperforms
Trump in these early states. Trump's done.
Now. I have said many times on my own programs,
DeSantis is far more dangerous than Donald Trump.
Right? He has all the same horrific policies,
but none of the baggage that makes him far more
dangerous. He can endear him selves himself.
Excuse me to the more moderate Republicans out
there, the people who may look at Trump and say,
No, I'm not going to do that again. They can
look at DeSantis and say, Oh, but I'll do that.
So let me explain the dangers here. Over the
last year and a half, everybody here on the left,
we've been talking about all these horrific laws
that have been passed state by state by state,
you know, a ban on books and critical race
theory up here, an abortion ban over here.
A transgender athlete banned there.
Transgender affirming care banned over there.
All of those things. Have happened here
in Florida and then some. You know,
you've got other states that have done
one or two of these things. Florida's
the only one that's done. All of them. All of
them. Not to mention the voter suppression,
not to mention the piece of legislation that
allows you as a motorist to run down a protester
if they're standing in the street and they're
in your way and not face any criminal charges.
Florida pioneered all this, folks. We have
all of the horrible pieces of legislation
crammed into one state. On top of that, our
economy is in the absolute toilet right now.
One of the most unaffordable states to live
in now are housing prices have risen faster
than any other state in this country under
Ron DeSantis. And he has done all of this,
tanked our economy, and, of course, passed
all this massively oppressive legislation.
In three years. In fact, almost all of it was
actually passed within the last 18 months.
He did. All of this damage
rose to national prominence
in 8 to 9 months, folks. Just imagine what he
could do with four years in the White House.
Now, personally, I don't know that DeSantis
would do well on a Republican debate stage.
The guy gets very flustered very easily. He loses
his temper. He gets, you know, kind of flustered
the way Marco Rubio did back in the 2015 debates,
which was hilarious to watch. So I don't know that
DeSantis could actually survive that, but if he
did, he may be a shoo in. And he would be very
difficult for any Democrat to beat. Definitely
difficult for any Republican to beat. Because as
as as horrible as this legislation is as bad as
some of the things he said, ah, he doesn't have
any real scandals, you know, there's no real
skeletons in the closet. He's just a bad guy.
And unfortunately, a lot of this legislation
that we look at as just absolutely repulsive
and oppressive. Most people do support a
lot of it. Not all of it, but a lot of it.
That's the worst part. It's
not turning off enough people.
So DeSantis finally pulling ahead of
Trump in the state of New Hampshire.
That's bad. It's not bad for, you know,
Trump really is bad for the United States.
We have to take another break. Again, I am fair
and cousins find me on YouTube, youtube.com,
slash the ring of fire and YouTube.com slash
fair and balanced. And I also host the weekly
Ring of Fire podcast. You can check that out for
free, or you can become a member if you'd like
at our o-F podcast dot com again on Farron Cousins
in for David Pakman. And we'll be right back.